des routes pour le modem et débâcle pour
le front national qui ne recueille qu'un
peu plus de 4% des suffrages c'est l'un
des plus mauvais scores de l'histoire du
fn et le parti de jean-marie le pen
n'aura même pas de pouvoir de nuisance
puisque il n'arbitrera pas de
triangulaire seule marine le pen s'en
sort plutôt bien à hénin-beaumont dans
le pas-de-calais nicolas chateauneuf
dominique masse des militants gonflés à
bloc pour encourager leur championne
marine le pen en pleine débarque du
front national la fille du chef est la
seule à pouvoir se maintenir au second
tour
alors ici à hénin beaumont on le vit
presque comme une victoire ce soir la
14e saison représente l'espoir pour
l'ensemble du front national très
critiquée à l'intérieur du parti pour sa
stratégie aux présidentielle marine le
pen jouer gros dimanche prochain le
match sera difficile mais il faut déjà
penser à la suite
le front national n'est pas mort vous
nous avez déjà enterré à de multiples
reprises
moi je crois qu'il y a un grand espoir
dans l'avenir et je demande aux
militants et aux adhérents surtout de ne
pas baisser les bras parce que nicolas
sarkozy décevra quoi qu'il arrive
contraste saisissant au paquebot le qg
du front les militants semblent un peu
perdus
le chef tente de faire bonne figure
devant les caméras mais difficile de
masquer l'immense déception 4% au lieu
de onze
en 2002 le très mauvais score du parti
entraînera une baisse des subventions
le front national va peut-être devoir
licencier
nous adapterons notre notre appareil
professionnel en particulier aux moyens
qui sont les nôtres
ouah à moins que d'ici là les les
adhérents du front national ne consente
un grand effort financier et
participation plus forte et auquel cas
nous pallieront les inconvénients de
cette de ce recul
seule petite consolation pour jean marie
le pen à vitrolles le candidat du fn a
devancé de cinq points son ancien bras
droit
bruno mégret